let me turn now and finally to the issue
of skills and not Studies on that as on
everything else I want to be as open and
transparent as possible my view is that
it is now inevitable that we will close
schools and nurseries and my planning
assumption now is that schools will
close to pupils at the end of this week
and I wanted today to give parents
notice of that know there are two key
drivers of that view first as the
science Sager expert scientific advisors
are examining new advice literally as we
speak I expect that that is likely to
tell us to close schools secondly we
have the reality on the ground as people
do the right thing and follow the advice
to self isolate or to isolate as a
household more and more skills are
approaching a point where they have lost
too many staff tick in ten years
normally we are working closely with
schools and tomorrow the Deputy First
Minister will set out in a statement to
Parliament the arrangements we are
putting in place in particular he will
address key questions that I know
parents pupils and teachers will have
including what this will mean for
vulnerable people's those receiving free
school meals because we must not cut
adrift vulnerable children secondly what
this means for pupils taking that exams
this year because we will not blade the
life chances of our children and
crucially what this means for key
workers we must ensure that our doctors
nurses another critical staff can still
work laser on the lane if they cannot I
want to be open with people that we are
still working out all of the fine detail
of what exactly this will mean it is
important to know that they will
doubtless require to be a lot of local
flexibility required and why we will set
out maximum detail to model planning
with councils is likely to go on well
into next week in some areas private not
cities and chow mein ders can play a
massive role in helping key workers keep
going and other areas councils will use
school buildings to reach vulnerable
children we will
or any and every plan that helps people
make this work and to reassure teachers
and all school staff as well as those in
the nursery sector we will work with you
in the coming days because other than
parents themselves we know that you know
children based and we know you will step
up to help because we know how committed
you are to the children you teach and
those that you care for there will be a
vital role for teachers and all school
and nursery staff in the weeks ahead
finally on the question that I know
parents and the wider public will have
of how long this will last
the pleaders guidance I can give know is
that people should not assume that
schools and nurseries will reopen after
the Easter break we will of course only
keep them closed for as long as we
absolutely have to but at this stage I
cannot promise that they will reopen
before the summer holidays let me say
that this has been one of the hardest
decisions we have faced so far as we
tackle this virus we know that this will
massively disrupt life society and the
economy we know that it massively
changed his family life and nothing is
more precious than that but that indeed
is the measure of how serious this virus
is and how serious the challenge is that
we face